[Music]
thank you
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
to other people's working on censor
world's rugby bans the legendary Anthem
Delilah of the claims it normalizes
violence against women does that mean we
now cancel violent television violent
movies operas even Shakespeare we'll
debate that
at first Boris Johnson went on maneuvers
now let his Liz truss launches the most
unwanted comeback in political history a
Britain's zombie ex-prime ministers
undermining which is two next government
plus Sam Smith shocks what is always
shocking and why it's even a news story
but he's shocked again at the Grammys by
dressing up as Satan is he they them
bravely pushing the boundaries of art or
just the boundaries of taste or debate
that
Piers Morgan uncensored good evening
from London welcome to Piers Morgan on
censored there are very few sights and
sounds more iconic in British sport than
Welsh rugby fans lusterly bellowing out
Delilah it's a legendary 1960s ballot by
the iconic Welsh crooner Tom Jones and
here's the man himself leading A rousing
Chorus of it at Wembley for the England
v Wales game in 1999.
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
tingling stuff like many sporting
anthems there's nothing much to do with
sport it's a stirring sing-along Anthem
which every supporter knows the words to
it gets their pulses racing it raises
the roof it brings fans together but
does it incite violence well the Ross
Rugby Union thinks so it's just banned
the song from the official choir song
list ahead of the Six Nations opening
fixtures which just occurred this
weekend and a victory for common sense
and it was their own adventure this
weekend the Welsh fans completely
ignored him
before
they come to break down the door
[Music]
I didn't help their play Wales got
wallet by Island in that opening game on
Saturday some suggested I should have
spent more time concentrating on the
rugby a little less time on The Virtue
signaling well the Wales Winger Louis
zamet tweeted all the things they need
to do and they do that first he's got a
point hasn't he the Walsh Rugby Union
said in the statement that the song is
problematic that wonderful new word that
scourge of our society problematic
everything is problematic to somebody
trust me everything
but problematic and upsetting to some
supporters because of its subject matter
and it's true the lyrics to Delilah are
pretty full-on they're about a jealous
lover avenging his Unfaithful concubine
she stood there laughing at them and
life in my hand and she laughed no more
we can all agree that's not the way to
settle the real domestic dispute but as
any real person in the 55-year history
of the song ever seriously interpreted
it as an instruction manual does anyone
think there's anything to do with
domestic violence the songs Just theater
it's a thespian murder ballad telling a
fictional story about people who don't
exist if we have to ban Delilah where
does that stop Johnny Cash shot a man in
Reno just to watch him die that wasn't
very nice Bob Marley shot a sheriff that
was definitely problematic and don't
even think about Britney Spears singing
Hit Me Baby One More Time
Happy Valley is the biggest show on
British TV at the moment it features a
lot of violence against women which it
uses as part of its masterful and
hard-hitting storytelling movies are
loaded with exaggerated violence against
men women and well pretty much everybody
then there's Opera theater Shakespeare
the entire genre of rap music
Banning one Welsh Anthem might seem
trivial to some but once you begin to
sacrifice art at the altar of
snowflakeery as I would see it the world
starts to become a very boring Place
well joining me now is domestic abuse
Survivor and the founder of stand up to
domestic abuse Rachel Williams and my
pack legal journalist Ava Santina taught
to be contributor Esther cracker welcome
to all of you so Rachel
first of all you've been through a
horrific thing
horrific domestic violence ending up
with you being shot and it had appalling
consequences your own son took his life
after this and for that I'm deeply sorry
to you and genuinely I
have nothing to offer you but empathy
for everything you've been through
here's my problem with this is I can
understand why you
give them what you've been through
given the choice would say yeah stop
singing Delilah but for the reasons I've
just articulated that once you start
going down that road with with
fictitious art
I don't know where it ends most operas
have similar storylines Shakespeare's
full of it do we literally say that's it
that all that kind of stuff has to be
expunged canceled well I'm well I love
Tom I used to sing along with gusto you
know not really knowing the words and
this is what I found in the last couple
of weeks people are singing it not
knowing the words and I think if it was
put up on a big screen in the in the
match would people really want to be
seeing that the glorifying of a murder
no we know we lose two women a week at
the hands of a partner or ex partner is
ban in Delilah they're going to stop a
perpetrator of course it's not and
anybody that thinks that is absolutely
insane so why bother well I think you
know we talk about Happy Valley you know
that was great because it showed
domestic abuse showed coercion showed
the murder showed the violence but then
his good cut back up he he got done for
his actions basically this is actually
glorifying a song of a murder and I
think unless you've been touched by
domestic abuse and violence directly or
indirectly it's or somebody else's
business but if you took the argument
it's not get it yeah I get it I totally
get why you feel the way you do but if
you take the argument that if you've
personally experienced something which
is you know for you a serious thing and
it upsets you and it's traumatizing that
no art can ever go down that road
because it might upset somebody who's
been through it themselves for real I
just think in the end I'm bringing the
pack here but I just think in the end
Esther once you go down that road it's a
very slippery slope to really rampant
censorship yeah because somebody
somewhere will have a story not as bad
as yours I would hope because it's
horrific but somebody will have a story
about almost everything which they could
say look this is traumatizing me this
Shakespeare play this performance of it
you know this Opera I mean the operas in
particular I'm thinking of this poem I
mean there's all sorts of stuff where
even modern pop music where you know you
might recite poetry you might recite it
you know I have a school play of
Shakespeare I was a Shakespeare
performer myself a prep school dude when
I look back on it Romeo and Juliet you
know these things are they're all pretty
violent yeah I mean it's a free speech
issue right you know everything will at
some point can and will offend someone
else but at the point where you're
infringing on someone's free speech to
actually sing the song because you think
they're not cognizant of the the content
of the lyrics or whether they should be
singing it that is where it's a slippery
slope because then you have to be able
to justify it you have to be able to
prove that that song is an instruction
manual for people that want to you know
solve domestic disputes which is not no
one's murdered a woman because they said
I listened to that that the song Delilah
and followed the lyrics right and and
the bigger issue here is you know listen
to the filth that we listen to today 50
cents you know uh stormzy all look at
the lyrics of all the money and pop
songs that we listen to they're all full
of violence and you know glorifying
horrible things but we still sing them
and most people know the lyrics they
just choose to ignore them right that's
just that's just the nature of this
right I mean that's that is my feeling
about this if you're going to start
Banning Delilah it's a bit like when
they they went after the the Christmas
song The what was it Baby It's Cold
Outside yeah and they said it you know
it was basically a license to commit
assault on women everybody with a brain
knew that was not the case about that it
was a very innocent song actually in a
very innocent video about playful
flirtation but he got a misconstrued
John Legend rewrote the lyrics because
it was so outrageous but John Legend is
best friends with a bunch of rap stars
who write and sing the most heinous
stuff so to me there's a real double
standard too about what we delve into
when it comes to censoring music but
that's interesting that you understand
that dichotomy and then I understand
later in this program we're going to be
talking about Sam Smith and the display
that they put on yesterday at the
Grammys a display that I really enjoyed
it was Satan you can understand that you
can understand how that might be
influential on children who are watching
on impressionable people but for some
reason you can't understand why chanting
about murdering someone
the difference is not murdering
someone's murdering a woman so imagine
if Delilah was written and sung by a
woman right that's just a woman who shot
the sheriff what happens
Bob Marley I Shot the Sheriff yeah so
what happens to that song well what do
you mean are we in a situation
are we saying it only matters if a woman
you know is it only applicable to women
being on the receiving end of violence
well I think that I think you are very
intelligent peers and you know that
women are often on the end the receiving
end of domestic abuse you know a woman
is killed every three days by a partner
but it dwarfs that number the number of
men that are killed by other than that
dwarfs the numbers
on that point I have made a series of
crime documentaries involving extremely
violent women just for the record a two
series called Killer Women and they were
incredibly dangerous and very violent so
it's not like dangerous women don't
exist the percentage is higher but the
highest percentage of killings in the
world by a country mile as Esther said
is men on men right but my point is okay
you know Bob Marley I Shot the Sheriff
did we ban that song
let me slightly agree with you and say
what I didn't like about this band was I
felt that the Welsh Rugby Union had
actually engaged in Ben washing which is
essentially like you know I'll tell you
it sounds like one of those things that
you see yeah exactly it's a hygienic
product and it's capitalizing on
domestic abuse and women's violence in a
way to publicize yourself and actually
yeah Banning this song is not going to
do anything to the you know to combat
the way that women are treated by
violent husbands who come home from
sports games if they'd actually done
something productive alongside this band
I'd be more on side with it but I think
they have trivialized domestic abuse
with this just this quiet ban okay so
mother question look you said you sang
along it's been a Welsh anthem for 50
years right so it came out in the 60s
why now I mean we've all known what the
lyrics have been everyone knows what the
song is is everyone why now I think if
I'm truly honest it is in response to
what's just coming with the wru you know
and I've been talking about this song
for the last few years and so was Chris
Bryant the MP and I had a Twitter debate
with a gentleman on Twitter and he said
you know oh it's ridiculous and then
when I explained to him my reasons of
why I think it should not be certain he
said he totally agreed you know 92
percent of defendants in domestic abuse
cases in 2020 weren't were male you know
we've got a problem but here's again I
come as a complete respect again for
your argument I get it but here's the
problem
to me there are two issues domestic
violence and Free Speech right nobody is
saying that these are real people in
Delight they're fictitious and someone
is really happening every week
but Happy Valley is fictitious yes but
then you had the cop at the end so if
Tom Jones rewrote the lyrics and the the
guy who kills the woman gets gets put in
jail you're fine with it if that's if
that if that'll still be it yeah really
yeah you'd be fine with it keep the
lyrics so your interpretation of it is
the standards my thing is at the end of
the day is good cop back up and at the
end of the day you've got a case like
with Happy Valley where he was actually
arrested put in prison and you know
if the story ends the way you want it
that's when it's okay Free Speech but no
it's it's you know I I thought of
Delilah took the knife what if Delilah
saw the man at the door and said oh you
know I'm sick of you and just went into
a kitchen and got a butcher's knife no I
think we are trivialized you're happy to
manipulate a story
no it's not because at the end of the
day if if the guy if delagola killed the
guy then you know we could still have
the same conversation
we wouldn't be having a conversation
exactly no because
I understand yes but as we just said far
more men are killed by men
and it's promoting violence constantly
this is a sick world that's the entirety
of the rap job okay the entirety rugby
rugby itself promotes violence its men
smashing into each other right it's
violent yeah but they choose to do that
well the woman don't naturally killed or
smacked around he doesn't choose not to
sing the song but you don't get to you
don't get to make that blanket he says
more about the person singing the song
lyrics if you know the lyrics
but would you though go over any Opera
that had problematic you know narratives
or themes would you go over any other
songs which have violence in them would
you ban all rap music
you know you know that's a harmisha
stalkers you know Every Breath You Take
every move you make you no I get I'm not
gonna ban everybody no you can I would
love to ban that song
that is a terribly frightening song I
cannot stand it Every Breath You Take
it's creepy yeah it's about a man
watching his ex-wife forever it's
stalking that's nice but it sounds like
it's very nice
as well what else you want to burn I'd
happily I'd happily get rid of that
you'd happily get rid of most rap music
it's interesting to hear when you talk
about yesterday I'm sure and I've spoken
to you before about I've never said it
should be banned no I've only ever said
I don't think any of it should be banned
I think fictitious music lyrics like
everything else fictitious they should
be treated as fictitious and I don't see
a causal link between Delilah and people
suffering domestic violence I just don't
if there was one if it was a Spate of
cases and people say well actually I
listened to Tom Jones sing this at the
rugby and it made me want to go and kill
my partner fine you don't there's ever
been a recorded case of them you don't
think that chanting it over and over
again
I don't think anybody ever has ever gone
away from chanting Delight or anything I
must go and kill my girlfriend well then
it's okay for Sam Smith to dress up as
Satan as well my point about Sarah Smith
is he's become a bit like his heroine
Madonna he's become this ridiculous
attention seeker who only shocks just to
just to create shock and attention the
reason I don't injection to this is an
economy about the New York Post there
are 210 million Christians in America 63
of the country who are actually
genuinely offended
with prancing around on stage at the
Grammys family show watched by kids he's
prancing around devil worshiping and
actually making a point of saying well
they don't recognize trans people so we
view them as hellish right yeah but then
but but why do you get to ban Free
Speech where you get to promote Free
Speech when it's Delilah but then when
this comes on and it might offend a
certain subsect of America I'm not
saying you should be it's not
appropriate because it might offend you
can't be critical people it could be
critical I just don't believe in this
cancel culture all the time I don't
believe you keep Banning things because
you don't you don't find them
appropriate you can sing Delilah at home
you can go home and sing Every Breath
You Take No one is stopping you from
doing that we're just suggesting that
maybe in a stadium full of people where
women and children like to take part in
the action it's not appropriate yes
you're not suggesting it you're Banning
it that's the difference you're not
suggesting it now it's been banned I
didn't buy anything
so if your mum was tragically killed by
by her partner knife to death would you
be happy singing that in a rugby match I
I wouldn't have any correlation between
that and a Delilah no no you wouldn't no
none of them unless it happened because
of the song Delilah my dad's a Welshman
and a massive fan of Welsh rugby if he
suddenly you know got over excited
watching the rugby because Delilah was
being so I'm gonna attack my mother I
might have a problem with it but I don't
see any causal link between the two
things and that's where I have a problem
with the censorship if there was I'd say
okay I get it and again I completely
understand why you feel the way you do
but I do think once you go down that
road I'm not sure where it stops because
there'll be a lot of people out there
who have their own reasons like you say
it is Every Breath You Take about
stalking I don't think so but there'll
be someone who's a stalking victim who
has the same powerful argument that you
do who's been through a horrendous
experience with stalking and says yes
and I get that and I get I get each
individual case I don't think you can
really legislate free speech by saying
every individual that suffer personal
trauma means we have to ban this thing
and and like I said all along peers you
know at the end of the day perpetrators
abuse because they choose not because of
alcohol not because of drinks not
because of their childhood background
and not because of Delilah right but the
good thing What's Happening Here is
we're having the conversation about
domestic abuse and violence and it's
being brought back into the medium I
agree and I think that's an important
issue and I know you've been through an
awful lot and it's great to see so thank
you very much for coming in appreciate
it you're staying with me back next
tonight the Fallout to my students
interview with prime minister rushi
sunak and the ghastly Return of the most
unwanted prime minister in history the
lettuce
there's truss or next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no with the people's Channel no we're
gonna use every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember a thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
foreign
Waters the Tory sharks circling the
Prime Minister Liz truss and Boris
Johnson are pushing the tax cuts ahead
of the budget remember the last time the
Government tried the trust way the pound
tank to mortgage rates exploded and she
was gone in 44 days in fact she lasted
less time than a lettuce you might
remember
well maybe we should see that next to
take the advice that I gave him during
our interview
is it time to put the Periscope up and
unleash a little torpedo to remind Boris
who the actual prime minister is
we're driving that is a former
conservative party chairman sir Jake
Berry Ava and Esther still here and I'm
joined by talk to these piglets okay I'm
going to start with Kate McCann in
Westminster the list trusts come back
that nobody forecasts and nobody seems
to want why is this happening why is she
not taking a dignified period of Silence
of say 20 years as we try and forget the
damage he wrought on our economy
yep is I think that's a question that
actually Lots in the conservative party
not least in the country are asking
themselves too what's clear from the 4
000 word piece that Liz truss wrote over
the weekend and the interview that she's
done this evening with spectator TV is
that she feels she's going to play a
role in reshaping not just the
conservative party but the whole of
politics's approach to economics she
thinks essentially that Rishi sunak and
those in government right now have got
it wrong and she seems to feel some kind
of Duty to try and set it right and
what's fascinating about reading her
interview and her reasoning for why
things went the way they did is that
there's a lot of blame levied on a lot
of different people the obr comes in for
some
literal and not not phrased enough in
economics we're not economically
literate we play a part two she's
clearly thought about the reasons why
she believes things went wrong for her
but I think the mood in the conservative
party is pretty much not right now thank
you very much even though there are many
Adventures
not right now it's not never thanks it's
unbelievable I mean I read this 4 000
word thing she blamed absolutely
everybody and even found a way to blame
the labor party which I hadn't factored
into this at all because last time I
checked she was thrown out by her own
side not by the labor party but also the
idea you could be prime minister for 44
days that you can be outlasted by a
lettuce in a tabloid stunt that you tank
the pound to record lows that you cause
immeasurable damage to individual
households with soaring mortgages and
and so on the idea that you don't even
include the word sorry in this 4 000
word piece that you blame everybody else
and that you very grandly say I don't
think I'll be making a comeback as prime
minister no one's going to ask you sorry
yeah well I mean I think she evidently
feels like she was unfairly turfed out
and she's gone away thought about it
come back and explained all the reasons
why she feels it wasn't fair I mean I
think the most telling moment for me and
what we've seen from her over the last
24 hours was she still doesn't really
seem to have an answer to the question
of why she sacked her own Chancellor
which she would think she had spent some
time thinking about and you're right you
know this does have a huge impact now on
the party itself I mean you've got Jake
Barry there I'm sure that he will tell
you that Rishi sunak will be able to
carry on and and the prime minister is
setting his own course but the reality
is that there are those in the Tory
party which is kind of what I was about
to say before who would like to see the
chancellor cut taxes in the budget and
we've had a very clear signal from
number 10 that that is not going to
happen and remember we're not that far
out from a general election and there
are lots of conservative MPS worried
about whether or not they'll be able to
keep their seats who would like to see
more action from the Prime Minister who
doesn't feel himself that now is the
right time to run I'm just trying to
wonder I'll bring in jail I'm just
trying to wonder how stupid you have to
be as a conservative Member of
Parliament to think the best thing that
Rishi suneck could do right now is the
thing that Liz trust did which tanked
the pound virtually collapsed our
economy almost led to us debunding
ourselves and led to having to leave
after 44 days as the record worst prime
minister in history what part of the
brain of any Tory MP and by the way if
you're one of them I include you so this
is your chance to to either convict
yourself or acquit but what part of that
thinking is anything other than Insanity
I mean it'd be like the old Einstein
thing the definition of insanity doing
the same thing again and again expecting
a different result
well players look Richie sunak himself
is committed to lower taxes before the
next general election looking at the
basic rate of income tax that's
something I support I think families up
and down this country realize there's a
little bit too much month and not enough
salary in a great way of helping them
out is to cut their taxes but he said
he'll do it in his own time when it's
right for the economy we all want to cut
our taxes right everybody wants to spend
MPS
but the Mantra of the party I keep
hearing is and this is for people that I
know for example worship Margaret
Thatcher right Margaret Thatcher I don't
know where this myth has developed the
first thing she did with Slash taxes she
didn't the first thing she did with the
tricky economy that she inherented was
she stabilized the economy and when she
was comfortable about it being stable
then she cut income tax dramatically and
it was a huge success that's clearly
what should be happening here you
stabilize the economy first the
inflation is still raging away at these
huge levels what you don't do is pour
petrol onto the inflation bonfire at
this particularly perilous moment here I
mean it's mad well Margaret Thatcher did
spend the first part of her Premiership
reforming the Civil Service which I
absolutely think we need to do and one
of the things Liz has said is that the
civil service has a sort of a you know a
sort of institutional bias against tax
cuts and brexit she said recently today
you know people will make their own mind
about that and she rolled the pitch for
tax cuts that led to a sustained period
of austerity in the United Kingdom do I
wish Liz truss had taken that approach
yes I think she should have done I think
it would have been a much better way of
dealing with it do as a conservative I
believe actually we've got the highest
taxes in this country that we've known
in our peacetime history I don't think
they could go any higher and I think if
you accept that they shouldn't go higher
then you are then ultimately one reason
for taxes not if we cut taxes peers one
of the reasons of course eventually we
want to cut taxes but one of the reasons
they're so astronomically high right now
is to repair a lot of the damage that
Liz trust caused with her farcical 44
days her in quasi quality pulled this
country's economy to his knees the idea
she popped up so soon I find it actually
insulting to this country to be a
lecturer to the people the millions of
people paying through their nose now for
the mortgages I find it insulting that
Liz truss is dare to rear her face so
soon and it's and is not blaming anybody
it's not blaming yourself but everybody
else is to blame including the labor
party apparently it's a left-wing
conspiracy that forced her to do what
she did no it was ignorance of the
markets and of the economy full stop end
well I do accept your premise that taxes
are high now because it's repairing what
happened I said they're higher than they
would be because the damage because we
are coming out of a moment of national
crisis in terms of covert that's why
taxes
Jake one moment you've questioned me so
just to be clear I said the reason
they've had to go so stratospherically
higher again is because of the damage
that she caused and we've had to repair
it Jeremy hunts had no option Norse
Richie sumac the reason taxes are high
is because we're coming out of the cable
pandemic but on the issue of time I
think look it doesn't matter where you
think blame laws I think the British
people wanted to hear what from Liz I
think they wanted to hear sorry I think
it was a mistake not to say that and
then frankly whoever isn't you know who
wherever the blame lies the British
people look at this and go my mortgage
went up uh you know there was there was
a problem with the economy the bonding
yields went up it doesn't matter whose
fault it is they blame the government
they blame they say you are in charge
because because
played Russian roulette with the
country's finances but that's why it's
so important now that we deliver on this
pledge made by Richie to half him well
let's play a clip from my information is
the biggest challenge facing everything
interest rates went up again last week
oh this trust was an impact it's because
of inflation and that's why we've got it
I understand let's spend another clip
from my interview soon like about this
very subject
it's pretty much the worst imaginable
Hospital pass any incoming prime
minister could ever wish to receive
which begs the question what on Earth
did you want to do this for even though
it was going to be a nightmare job for
all the reasons that you outlined you
know I felt that I could make a
difference and I was the best person to
make a difference at that moment
especially given the challenges that
people were facing and what they were
seeing with their mortgages and that's
that's ultimately why I put myself
forward to do it and knowing that it
would be difficult and challenging but
ultimately doing what I thought was my
duty in that situation because I believe
deeply in service and and thought I
could make a difference of the country
now that got well received that
interview I think people appreciated
seeing a bit more of him than they
normally doing an interview able to show
a serious side and also a personal side
but I was quite impressed by the way he
said to me right I've got these pledges
come back and interview me at the end of
the year and give me the verdict then on
whether I've met them or not I like that
that gives me a genuine all of us a
Target right okay he's laid down his his
marker but the very last thing Rishi
sunat needs right now are the two
buffoons who came before him rearing
themselves up like we've been so hard
done by Going On Maneuvers and trying to
damage him and ship away right when the
party leads it needs at least you've
been party chairman what would you be
doing now with these two Renegades well
look the first thing is we've got to
work out what we want former prime
minister to do we're all quite critical
uh in the media and politicians alike of
Tony Blair and David Cameron virtually
immediately leaving office people saying
they're leaving to cash in we've then
got a whole series of prime ministers
who have stayed in power elements that
are involved in politics Gordon Brown
campaigned in the Scottish referendum
he's in fact writing large parts of the
labor party's Manifesto for them now in
relation to Devolution when we have
Prime Ministers coming in in their early
40s we have to work out what they're
going to do next I think the prime
ministerial interventions they're
uniquely understand how challenging the
job is of being a prime minister in that
interview I heard Rishi sunai say to you
that he in fact speaks to all the former
former conservative prime minister Party
leaders and talks to them about advice
but uniquely they know how challenging
the job is so interventions should be
infrequent and impactful okay and I
think that can actually help the debate
in this country Ava I mean I do find it
staggering here is Liz the lessis I do
find it staggering that we're even
having a conversation about Liz trust
making any kind of comeback yet and with
no remorse no apology just like it never
happened it was all somebody else's
fault and by the way I was right yeah
and I think the other thing I take away
that I'm a little bit frightened to hear
Jake is your defensive list trust and
that low tax policy because the first
time that you enacted that you spooked
the markets and you write an investment
away from the UK and actually investors
are still frightened to put their money
into our country and if they think that
people on the back benches MPS on the
back benches are going to still go for
this low tax policy and might brighten
the markets again they're never going to
bring anything here it's not low tax
policy one of the highest we are we're
in the highest
nation has ever been under perhaps you
think they should go up I actually think
that we are
apparently people talk about touch
that's not what I said when you've
advocated for a low tax policy squeaking
you you're talking to ordinary Working
Families up and down this country and
what they want is the government to give
them a break to give them a tax cut to
let them keep something I I agree with
you but I think we're conflating two
different issues here I think I can't
believe I'm defending list trust but she
you know investment in the UK was we
were the lowest of the G7 in terms of
investment for a decade preceding
brexits so clearly let's trust in awful
way was trying to fix a structural issue
with Britain's economy by trying to
attracting the gun but exactly but the
communication was off I mean the whole
strategy was not listening exactly I
think what's the biggest issue with her
comeback is the fact the lack of the
word sorry and I think we have to
acknowledge that no one is against low
taxes conservatives even labor you know
labor um traditional labor voters who
are hard-working people want lower taxes
but it's the way she went about it the
fact that she's blamed no one everyone
else but herself and the fact that she's
really not kind of reading the room no
one wants to see let's trust back no no
but well maybe you do no no party has
agreed with the conservative party this
is the basic break of income tax should
fall over that is now agreed between the
two parties look Liz truss's diagnosis
of what is wrong with the economy about
being a low growth High tax economy that
is unable to fund Public Services is
correct was the prescription for that
disease right no it wasn't should she
have said sorry I actually said earlier
I think she should have done I think she
would have got a much better hearing for
this serious point that she wants to
make but we need to talk about okay
great growth in our economy to pay for
public service absolutely Jake good to
see you thanks for coming in I
appreciate it uh thank you to my pack
excellent today as always coming up how
big of a threat is a balloon from China
to the Mighty United States of America
well quite a big one according to Vivek
ramaswamy and he joins me next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you uh every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Felts is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back HC balloon that's become a
political scandal in America this is the
moment the suspected Chinese spy balloon
has finally shot down over South
Carolina after eight days drifting
across American airspace President Biden
has been accused of humiliating America
and emboldening China backed into slowly
the commander ensues says he decisively
commanded U.S forces to shoot down the
balloon which they eventually did on
Saturday where that was four days after
he said that well joining me now
I should go to clip I ordered the
Pentagon to shoot it down on Wednesday
as soon as possible
they decided without doing damage to
anyone on on the ground they decided
that the best time to do that was it got
over water outside within our within 12
mile limit
it successfully took it down and I want
to complement our aviators who did it
Top Gun Shades he sport in there the
president but joining me now is the
American entrepreneur and commentator
Swami or Vivek um you'll notice that the
anti-woke scourge of corporate wokeries
so it's good to have you on anyway and
we may get to that in a sec but just on
this issue of China and this balloon it
seemed to me a remarkable coincidence in
the run-up to President Biden's State of
the Union speech which is tomorrow night
you have a Chinese spy balloon just
wandering across American airspace for
eight days and it also revealed I think
what many people fear is the problem
with President Biden which is his
ineffectiveness when it comes to dealing
with
China and you just have this spy balloon
there nothing happening to it the days
on it
so look I actually think they were
purposefully waiting for that spy
balloon to fly over the ocean before
shooting it down precisely so they could
have plausible deniability because they
were afraid of what they would actually
find so what they're able to be able to
say to the public now if I'm able to
make a prediction is that they weren't
actually able to find the information so
they can't know even though they sent
these Navy divers down to find it the
problem is if they had shot it down
instantly over land they would have to
deal with what they actually saw and my
view is that China is not so incompetent
as some believe they are I think they
were sending a signal they have sent
these balloons in the past reportedly
but I think a big part of this was
showing who's in charge the idea that we
can send this balloon over your
territory and you're not really going to
do a darn thing about it and I'm sorry
to say that they were basically right
because shooting it down after it's over
the ocean was the equivalent of doing
nothing about it and then now the
outrage afterwards is just a faux
outrage from the CCP for whom lying is
but a habit of their culture and so
that's I think with essence of what's
going on here they flew these balloons
over Taiwan last year reportedly now
they're just sending that signal to the
United States as one more inch in
progressing towards sending their
projection of strength over us as a
people that's I think a big part of the
subtext of what was going on here and
what do you think is the likelihood of
China attacking Taiwan anytime soon a
lot of people think it is more likely
than not
so I've been talking about this for a
long time I think it is quite High I
think it goes up for every every little
bit it goes up further I think it was
not going to happen before October of
last year that's when Xi Jinping took
over his third term as leader of the CCP
he didn't want to disrupt the apple cart
but now that he's taken over it'd be the
perfect opportunity to show and project
Force there's a Taiwanese election
coming up in 2024. there's a U.S
election presidential election coming up
in 2024. if I were in their shoes you
would look at the current U.S president
and say that's a pretty good bet for
somebody who's not going to take
actually the right actions to deter this
that creates a potential window add to
that the fact that the U.S is actually
retreating and actually even retiring
some of its ships in the South China Sea
that creates a potential Nader of U.S
naval capacity in the South China Sea
right when China is actually ramping up
its shipping production and its Naval
capacity as well so I think it's
unfortunately the imperfect Confluence
which is to say from China's standpoint
the perfect Confluence of forces and
alignment of the star ours to say that
that moment to go after Taiwan could be
coming sooner than we want and I think
this balloon was really if I may say a
trial balloon right to say that you know
what we're going to invade your
sovereignty see what you're going to do
about it if the U.S didn't do anything
meaningful for that then I think that's
a test to say that the U.S may not do
anything right and they'll also hide his
eyes and China will also be watching
like a hawk what's happening in Ukraine
and seeing how big a stomach for the
fight the Americans have right because
there are there are increasing Rumblings
on the Republican side in particular in
the United States that they shouldn't be
spending all this money uh waging you
know a war sort of proxy war helping the
ukrainians defeat Vladimir Putin they
should be spending it on more pressing
domestic issues but I would argue
against that that if you let Putin win
in Ukraine that's a green light I would
say for China to go into Taiwan
well it's one step deeper than that
pierce if I may we don't depend on
Russia for our modern way of life in
fact even in the last Cold War the U.S
did not depend on the Soviet Union for
the shoes on our feet or the phones in
our pocket but the precarious position
with China and I think this is the
defining aspect of this cold war in the
21st century is the U.S depends on its
rival its enemy for powering its modern
way of life from the clothes we wear to
the electronics that we use and that's
what makes it so difficult to face down
China relative to facing down Russia so
I actually think that it's in some ways
it's a dis analogy because even if the
U.S could take on Vladimir Putin that's
the easy part in fact you know do a
thought experiment imagine this was a
Russian spy balloon there is little
doubt in my mind that the thing the U.S
would have done was to shoot it down
instantly and Ratchet up sanctions on
Russia and the reason they didn't do it
on China is because the U.S depends on
China for our modern way of life you
know the U.S declared independence from
the folks on your side of the pond in
1776 I think 2023 or 2024 needs to be
the year that the U.S declares
independence from China or else there's
no chance of actually you know who's
been saying that militarily 40 years
Donald Trump was one of one of the
things he was spot on about I remember
interviewing Donald Trump 15 years ago
and him telling me exactly that he just
got a he said China is basically
pillaging the U.S without the US really
realizing what's going on and it looks
like he was right
um Vivek great to talk to you thank you
very much come back again and talk about
uh anti-woke uh scourge of Corporations
we need we need your voice it's out of
control so please come back another time
we'll discuss that
we'll do that
Alexa like Sam Smith as the devil at the
Grammys Madonna looking barely human
because they all think it was Halloween
is this art or obscenity we'll debate
that next
[Music]
we're leading Britain's conversation oh
no uh with the people's Channel no what
are you uh every little helps for God's
sake is nothing original anymore it's
finger licking Goods I'm loving it look
let's be honest we don't have any fancy
speech writers here but we do and I
promise you discuss the issues that
matter to you yes I'm back talk TV not
with Morgan just before him Monday to
Thursday at 7pm join me just do it what
that one too
[Music]
thank you foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
foreign
world-class broadcaster Vanessa Feltz is
on talk TV every night of the week
[Music]
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
it's hard to keep up with Sam Smith's
identities but last night's Grammys they
as Smith now prefers to be called
identified as Satan the performance
while many deers especially amongst the
American Christian fraternity which are
210 million in America sometimes it Ted
Cruz said it was evil
well one of the scariest moments for me
wasn't Sam Smith as the devil it came
with Madonna's General appearance she
seemed not to have got the memo that
Halloween's in October
but are they Sam Smith pushing artistic
boundaries or just pushing the limits of
good taste shocking for the sake of it
outraging because why not it sells
records we're join me now to debate all
this it's Master Rowan who performs as
tripping Jupiter and the YouTuber and
commentator Lauren Chen to Lauren Chen
let's start with you I mean it's called
outraged this Sam Smith performance last
night he'll be quite pleased about that
because quite clearly a bit like Madonna
is heroin part of his stick is
deliberately creating outrage because it
fuels interest and headlines and sells
records
no you're absolutely right and people
have said that this is a controversial
move by Sam Smith this is not at all
controversial within Hollywood and I
want to be clear that Sam Smith did this
specifically to upset the American right
and Christians everywhere and to Virtue
signal to his fellow Hollywood members
and elitists that don't worry he's on
your team he hates all the things that
he's supposed to hate if he actually
wanted to be controversial in Hollywood
what he would do is actually come out in
favor of Traditional Values because we
know that would never happen in a
million years or he would heaven forbid
actually do something that's critical of
maybe Islam that would genuinely be
controversy but of course because that
would be popular among leftist elitists
he's not going to do that this is
actually in a lot of ways the safest
thing that Sam Smith could have done
yeah I mean now tripping Jupiter do I
call you tripping Jupiter or Monster
which one would you prefer
you could call me mad stuff Master thank
you for being on the program
um this reminds me a bit of the met the
Met Gala in New York and they all
suddenly wore crucifixes one year and as
a Catholic I read a column saying you
know what you wouldn't be doing this to
the Islam uh religion why would you just
do it to Catholicism and to Christianity
and that reminded me again exactly what
Lauren said about last night yeah you
can dress up as Satan and prance about
having a bit of devil worshiping just to
deliberately outrage 63 of Americans who
are Christians but given he wouldn't do
that with other religions which are
likely to lead to more serious
repercussions for him I thought it was a
bit cowardly if I'm honest
I mean I don't think there's anything
cowardly about Sam Smith
and you know if Lauren's suggesting
that they are doing this just for
publicity as far as like their identity
goes I mean people struggle their entire
lives with identity and the fact that
they can come to a place where they
feel secure enough to let it out and the
public is an amazing thing and a
beautiful thing and a really important
thing as far as the the the red glitter
hat with the devil horns and I'm sorry
Ted Cruz if anyone looks at Sam Smith
and thinks the word evil I think that
they might frighten a little too easily
as far as as far as the Catholic Church
goes I mean
um I can't think of a better uh
you know religion to criticize or to
tweak or because I mean I mean there's
like decades and Decades of of child
sexual abuse that got covered up so they
don't really have a right to stand out
and be outraged when they but they're
also decades there are decades and
Decades of Islamic fundamentalist
terrorism and the point that Lauren was
making I think rather powerfully was
that you wouldn't get Sam Smith mocking
Islam in a performance
because again I mean you wouldn't say
his character I'd say that is an example
of kind of cowardice because we all know
he wouldn't do that and what he did last
night I'd say the he I think he called
they they what they did last night uh
was a deliberate Act of provocation to a
group of people who represent nearly
two-thirds of America and I I'm I find
that an interesting strategic decision
you know this is this is somebody who
wants to sell records in America you
know it's a it's a risky strategy to
take on that number of Christians and
mock their religion in that way
I don't think anybody's religion was
marked at all and this album by Sam
Smith is it's phenomenal
um it's got really positive messaging to
it but like if you're going to talk
about artists pushing boundaries this is
what great artists do you go back to
David Bowie he was attacked and vilified
when he burst onto the scene Lady Gaga
over a dozen years ago or more coming
out same thing you could go back to I
mean so are you going to tell me you
don't like David Bowie you don't like
Lady Gaga because people were unhappy
and the interesting thing is with these
icons go back to Catherine Hepburn right
when she was doing movies she wore pants
and people freaked out the detractors
who push against people who push gender
boundaries nobody remembers their names
the problem I have with Sam Smith is
that they can't seem to work out what
they are so we went through a period
where he was identifying a apparently is
a straight man then he came out as gay
and everyone was applauded and then
within I think 18 months uh he decided
he wasn't a gay man anymore he was going
to be non-binary gender fluid and what
does it be called they it's quite hard
to keep up Lauren Chen not to be
disrespectful to they but it is hard to
keep up with Sam Smith because every 18
months or so he seems to like a
chameleon flip into something some other
new identity so and then we have to
respect that those titles that they now
want
now you're absolutely right and it's
interesting because I was looking back
to interviews when Sam Smith first came
out as gay and he actually back then
would say things along the lines of
there's more to me than my sexuality I
just want this to be normalized this
shouldn't be a whole thing which I mean
by today's 2023 standards that almost
makes him sound like a right-wing
extremist the idea that his sexuality
shouldn't Define himself but fast
forward to today apparently he's gotten
the memo that the trendy thing is to
come out as uh some sort of trendy new
gender every other day and I just want
to say in regard to Sam Smith dressing
as the devil that's that's not part of
your identity your fashion choices are
not part of your identity Sam Smith
deciding to in his music video where a
corset doesn't mean he's non-binary all
it means is that he's desperate for
attention has absolutely no sense of
fashion but also and talking to people
all around him right and talking to
people desperate of attention
um Mastin I just want to show you
Madonna's hate at the Grammys and just I
just wonder is this an example when you
look at Madonna at the Grammys last
night of where plastic surgery takes you
if you're not very careful
if you're asking me I'm not an expert on
plastic surgery so I prefer to go back
to Lauren's corner I just have a
question for both of you have we got the
picture Madonna sorry there we are yeah
sorry yeah go on master
well I I wish her well she's an icon
she's done great things in music and
influenced a lot of people my question
is why are conservatives the ultra
conservatives especially the only ones
who are obsessed with what people wear
obsessed with how people identify and
Obsession should run out of time but I
can answer one question I'm not a
conservative so if that helps you that
will help you debate
great to have you both come back again
soon that's it from me Keep It
Uncensored
foreign
[Music]
every little helps for God's sake is
nothing original anymore it's finger
licking Goods I'm loving it look let's
be honest we don't have any fancy speech
writers here but we do and I promise you
discuss the issues that matter to you
yes I'm back talk TV not with Morgan
just before him Monday to Thursday at 7
pm join me just do it well that one two
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored debating
the breaking news and talking to the
biggest names Piers Morgan is live every
week with a host of stars uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember
thinking it